the boys is mainly set in new york city
but if you're a torontonian like me you
probably know it was shot in toronto you
know
toronto the home of the maple leafs
drake and our crack smoking mayor
toronto has become a mecca for film and
television production
often being substituted for new york
which is exactly what happened when the
boys came to town
and yes one time they were shooting
right outside my apartment which was
pretty cool
so i thought it would be fun to give you
a little tour of my hometown see the
real locations where they shot in season
2
and how some well-placed cgi can make my
city
look like
okay enough of that but before we do
grab some milk and make sure to like and
subscribe so my last remaining serotonin
doesn't give up on me
on that note let's start with a funeral
translucence that is the
large led line concert hall is actually
the diamond schmidt theater in the
meridian arts
center i'm not sure if you have meridian
in the states but it's like a big
investment bank type thing here those
led lights made it perfect for the boys
as they could blast some homelander red
white and blue during his eulogy hey
remember the deep in sandusky ohio
unfortunately it's just our town's water
park
wet and wild i haven't been there since
i was like seven and a bird [ __ ] on me
and it's
not not the greatest memory i think
water's supposed to be fun
a few moments later eagle the archer
bales the deep out in a former toronto
police headquarters this place has been
used in other movies like
2015's academy award nominated spotlight
now let's take a look at the boys
hideout which is located at 1955 weston
road
quite a bit of ways away from the
downtown core
obviously the real hideout scenes aren't
filmed here those are on a set
but it's kind of cool to look at and if
you go to google maps you can see what's
likely a truck from the show because of
these orange
les cones whenever you see those around
the city you know something is shooting
nearby
you may have seen these giant ass silos
where agent rainer's head explodes
these are the victory soya mills and
they cgi'd this big dawn of the seven
poster on its side
these silos have actually been abandoned
since 1991
where they used to store soybeans now
they're considered a heritage site since
they were built in 1944
and will be incorporated into the new
portlands which brings me to our next
location
the portlands remember when kenji
totally flips over that boat
yeah that's lake ontario and lots of
films shoot around here
i think the ending of the shape of water
was filmed around here too
and when the deep is riding that whale
well that's lake ontario and whales
can't survive in lakes
our next stop is george street diner
where starlight blackmailed gekko now i
actually haven't eaten here but it's got
a great
old school 50s aesthetic and is a
popular brunch spot
if there's a subway scene it's almost
always shot at an abandoned toronto
subway stop called
lower bay this place has been used in
dozens of films like suicide squad and
is almost
exclusively a film set now after going
out of commission in 1966
after only six months of use glad to see
our tax dollars at work now here is
where you're gonna find out how
insane i am and that i have no life
remember tony cicero's the place where
butchers dropped off at the beginning of
episode two i couldn't find out where
this place was but i did some sleuthing
and noticed this graffiti in the back
that says you say tomato
i say tomato and i was like maybe it's
an east side mario's we have a couple of
those around the city
so then i cross-referenced all the east
side marios in toronto
and found it double checking it had the
same hanging motorcycle
in the front i am very lonely agent
rainer has her funeral at willowdale
presbyterian church and these interiors
for the girls get it done campaign
are done inside roy thompson hall now
roy thompson hall is
also the stand-in for vaught tower at
least the bases since the building is
only about eight stories high
they just basically add cgi to make the
tower look huge
kimiko and kenji walk down the esplanade
which has a bunch of bars and
restaurants notice the usa today
newspaper
bin but if you've ever been to toronto
you know these are definitely toronto
garbage bins now this one is
near and dear to my heart because it's
literally right outside my apartment
the whole battle between stormfront and
kenji takes place in an area called
regent park
those apartments that get blown up yeah
those are government subsidized housing
so i guess that's on par for stormfront
in some of the scenes you can even make
out part of the cn tower here's wiley
bridge where butcher and rebecca have
their fight about ryan it's actually
close to that wet'n'wild and is situated
in a conservation area hughie and
starlight have a chat outside the
queen's park subway station now i'm not
exactly sure how they shot this because
this corner is
super busy so they probably dished out a
ton of cash to shut it down for a few
hours
in episode 4 huey and starlight hook up
at the emporia motor court motel
this is supposed to be in the south but
it's actually the beach motel near
hamilton a city outside of toronto
kimiko and frenchie have their first tip
of the season
inside saint paul's church on bloor
street this is the largest anglican
church in the city which was originally
built in 1842 but this new portion you
see here was constructed in 1913. and
here is one of my
favorites of the season but you're
getting beat up in a bar called
sneaky d's i can't even begin to explain
how many times i've gotten drunk here
it's a popular bar and restaurant with
live music upstairs and in true toronto
fashion they're tearing it down soon to
build more condos
i thought this was pretty funny but that
alleyway where homelander and stormfront
boink is right next to an infamous bar
called crocodile rock it's basically the
city's cougar bar and on weekends you'll
have like middle age to older women come
down from the suburbs to hit on young
men i mean like
not that i would know anything about
that in episode 6 we get to see the
church of the collective which is owned
by the scottish rite club of hamilton
the beautiful facade here was
constructed by a tobacco millionaire and
the building is mainly used as a
restaurant and for weddings it's also
been used in other shows like the
handmaid's tale because it looks creepy
as [ __ ]
sage grove psychiatric hospital is
actually a former psych hospital called
saint thomas's
it's now abandoned and is even said to
be haunted this building was also used
in the guillermo del toro
produced scary stories to tell in the
dark the homelander in stormfront
rallies take place in front of pico
square which is right across the street
from roy thompson hall
aka vaught tower pico square was built
as part of toronto's postmodern metro
hall project
and meant to house the government of
metro toronto the jitterbean coffee
chain found in episode 7
doesn't really exist it's a place called
grinder coffee near where i used to work
now i tried to install their app but all
i got were pictures of naked men grace
mallory's swanky cia outpost is called
the falls view residence located between
lush forest and waterfalls along the
bruce trail which is canada's oldest and
longest marked footpath it's currently
privately owned by a family of five and
some say if you whisper lamplighter five
times in the mirror
you can hear the faint cries of
homebanger echo throughout the house
the vogelbaum mansion is actually
parkwood estate a giant home located in
oshawa
originally built for the former head of
gm r.s mclaughlin
if you've ever seen billy madison this
is the same house
remember that exploding head scene i
sure do i got demonetized for showing it
not bitter about it at all well they
actually board the courtroom set from
the show
suits which is filmed here in toronto i
just hope they cleaned it up after the
swanky restaurant butcher meet stan
edgar at is called the chase located
downtown
they utilize both the exterior and
upstairs interior which is located in
the historic dining building constructed
in 1897. now i know i couldn't get to
everything i skipped over almost all the
sets and focused just on the locations
but i hope this is a fun video to give
you a brief snippet of what the real
locations are like for the boys
thanks for watching everyone be sure to
like and subscribe and share and for
more bad takes you can follow me on
twitter and
instagram at thinkstoryyt until next
time remember
daddy loves you very much
you